hailing John McCain is once again the
media's favorite Republican well now
that he reportedly does not want
President Trump at his funeral and he
also wishes he hadn't picked Sarah Palin
and as his running mate back in 2008 but
McCain's fondness for the media hasn't
always been a two-way street as they
routinely have trashed him when it suits
their own purposes in a 2006 article
headlined John McCain the sellout
Express the Huffington Post called the
senator a quote pandering politician who
will stop at nothing to get elected well
mccrane's McCain's great sin well
agreeing to speak at Jerry Falwell is
Liberty University the Atlantic ran a
piece during the 2008 presidential
campaign titled McCain the sellout based
on a fear that the candidate might
govern as a conservative and in a 2010
Vanity Fair piece headlined the man who
never was McCain is called so desperate
to keep his Senate seat that he quote
reputed aid in repudiated his record his
principles and even his maverick
reputation entrenching himself as the
anti Obama we're here to talk about
McCain the man is James H Warner he was
a pow1 during the Vietnam War
jim was POWs for six years and also my
old colleague and the Reagan
administration a former policy adviser
to President Reagan and Frank Luntz
esteemed pollster he's going to show how
the media have used McCain over the
years to fit whatever narrative that
they find convenient at the moment it's
great to see both of you Jim I want to
talk to you first first of all it's
great to see you long time I was young
you were you you were even more handsome
back then back in 87 sharing an office
together that's before I got took on the
appearance of a homeless oh it's all
cool here Jim look you you better than
anyone know that they experienced that
John McCain is had in Vietnam you've
known him for a long long time and I
haven't seen him for a while but is it
is it surprise you that he at the end
decided you know he was going to make
his funeral plans and make it explicit
that Trump was not to be there yes
it does but I don't know how far
advanced this this cancer is but I know
that I was told that it is very
aggressive and to say the things like he
did about Sarah Palin that's that's look
I was with him I warmed up an audience
for him the day after the convention in
a little that big rally north of Detroit
and he tried to introduce me to Sarah
Palin and we couldn't get near her
because she was just mobbed by people he
was there and at the convention when he
introduced her and he saw the
electricity I'll tell you how it
affected us we were up in a booth I
turned to my left I was sitting next to
bud day the most decorated American
warrior in all history and Bud had tears
in his eyes he was so moved and that's
what the effect she had so for him to be
doing that I I'm not gonna hold anything
against John for what he says in the
last year you know I don't know how much
this disease has affected him but now
the John that I know was one of the
greatest heroes I ever knew I'm one of
the finest men I ever knew Frank Luntz
it is interesting to go back and see
those headlines from all of the elite
publications John McCain the sellout
John McCain the phony fraud all the
things I said but now he's hitting Trump
and you know he's obviously been a you
know at odds with Trump in a number of
policies immigration foreign policy
trade to name a few and now not just
because I think he's obviously suffering
terribly I've lost three friends to
glioblastoma in the last few years it's
a horrific disease but it you see the
the ebb and flow of their relationship
well it happened in 2000 when he was
running against w it happened in 2008
with Mitt Romney so this is nothing new
and John McCain understood how to use
the press to his own advantage it's one
of the reasons why he's such a good
politician but and by the way I want you
to know that it's an honor to sit next
to you and frankly I feel the same way
about any of these men they suffered
truly suffered in in prisoner of war and
it was Donald Trump I don't know
remember who I was asking him questions
in Iowa and he actually it was my
interview where he said that John
McCain's not a war hero now he walked
that back later on but McCain in the
press it's it seems like a pretty good
relationship well this is what SE Cupp
said today on I believe it was CNN let's
watch he is not a sellout and I think
having president Truong just because
he's the president come speak on on his
behalf are eulogize him or memorialize
him would be selling out and Senator
McCain I say this not just as his
daughter's best friend but as a
Republican who supported him Senator
McCain is everything that President
Trump is not I have to say that somebody
should have told Donald Trump before he
said that about John John was hit by a
Sam and he ejected and his airplane was
just disintegrating one of the wings
came off and as soon as his chute open
it broke both the wing so it was swung
around broke both of his arms and one of
his legs so I don't know how he was able
to open up his Mae West much less how he
could swim well I have no idea how he
survived in the lake but I know that he
could not possibly have done any
resistance because as he was helpless
for several several weeks after that but
day had to take care of him but they had
to feed him well you could you hear him
where you were and I know I hope I lived
with him for two years okay in the same
but you were separated for because you
were there for six years and you were
separated for a long time yeah
but I in 71 there was a big uprising
amongst us and John McCain is even
though bud day was a senior man in his
cell John McCain was credited with being
the leader of that in fact on March 19
where they took 36 of us out we thought
we honestly thought we were being taken
out to be executed and John McCain
made a joke about it Wow a man who can
volunteer to die for religious freedom
that
what it was and make a joke about it is
really a top guy in my I mean I hold him
almost the same status as James
Stockdale Wow well you know it's to just
hear these stories Frank and he went go
home
they date they said to him go home yeah
but because he wasn't in the in terms of
being captured he refused and so they
beat him for it and those at a critical
of him because I don't like how he's
voted on certain issues who among us in
this studio would give our legs our arms
our body our lives she also said it's
fine he also said I think at one time
like I was a POWs but we can disagree I
mean just because there were a lot of
like John John Kerry was you know he
served his country proudly when the
Bronze Star vis but we disagreed with
him on a lot of issues so it's okay to
disagree with people it's just cuz you
disagree with him on a lot of issues and
yeah I assume you wouldn't disinvite
trump to your funeral but that's his
decision he wants to do that but the
media are playing this cynically Frank
that's what I'm saying they're playing
it when he when he's with the
Conservatives when he was running for
re-election he's strong on immigration
he's strong they were hitting him but
when he's hitting Trump a different deal
I hope that he that he is still alive I
hope that he still gets a chance to see
that in the end in so many areas so many
areas not all that he was right that he
was courageous and that in the end there
was someone that we can say to our
children that is a role model and think
of how few role models we have today no
I don't like what they said about Sarah
Palin I don't think that was necessary
and I think if you don't want Trump to
be at your funeral you can just say you
can make it known I don't think you have
to like write it in the book and our
ways I mean look you can do it everyone
can do what they want but like there's a
way to get that message out without like
but that's what his career we should not
judge him although I I say what he's
saying right now I can't now you know
it's I don't know how much that disease
has affected him but I know it's the
frontal lobes and that's where you think
and by the way Jim when you were because
you showed me this book you wrote a
calculus book was that writers ear
analytic geometry calculus and
differentiation to me at the White House
that was like 23 I still
don't understand calculus you're writing
this while you're a prisoner of war for
like 100 pages on this tiny little book
and I tell that story all the time
actually it's now in the Marine Corps
archives you can go to Quantico and see
of course it is you are amazing
I love you and I adore you Frank thank
you for being with us a great
conversation and God bless John McCain
his entire family it is a brutal disease
we need to find a cure for for all
cancers but glioblastoma is especially
awful